il y a un an ils ont mis sur internet une
grosse vidéo gratuitement
perso je dirais que c'est un [ __ ] de
film mais faut pas te dire
ouais ok ouais
ben ok ben tu sais chanela c'était tout toi et aujourd'hui pour l'
anniversaire ils peuvent oh mon Dieu  dieu
DVD pour moi ou attraper je viens de faire le premier DV au monde
sachez ce que je n'ai pas fait avant que
vous n'inventiez le DVD oh mon dieu c'est tellement
nouveau non je ne fais que diviser cet aïkido allez
les gars donnez-vous un peu de crédit que
vous venez d'inventer  une nouvelle technologie un CD
vous pouvez regarder un film qu'est-ce que c'est
que c'est comme des railleries vous êtes géniaux
puis-je jouer avec mon magnétoscope d'accord mais vous
pourriez dire pourquoi achèterais-je un DVD s'il est
déjà sur Internet gratuitement parce que
vous  [ __ ] de chatte il y a beaucoup de
fonctionnalités spéciales sur ce DVD un
documentaire idiot sur la réalisation du film
jeu d'optimiseur de miss sur tawa voir les
particules moins email la description que vous
voyez c'est un peu les poignarder toutes les
richesses commençons cette pièce parce que l'
extrait augmente sur  Westerley  épiderme
sur les quelques lunes semaines par semaine comme un lit
le morceau ils ne me tuent pas corps
oh vous les gars n'avez pas fait les choses avec
sa fille comme un an mais ce n'est pas
frais j'ai beaucoup d'argent pour un dollar bêtisier hilarant
ne l'obtiendra jamais Dieu le fera  je ne veux pas que
je fasse le pari de hockey j'ai faufilé
ce nyla oh alors non non non non je
ris déjà mon [ __ ] de cul et
aussi un commentaire audio de Surya cata
son original piste un livret de 32 pages
et beaucoup de  Oeufs de Pâques,
vous pouvez également acheter des t-shirts surio cutter
shirt et Naga Lee est sûr que la même chose
qu'elle porte dans le film,
vous pouvez vérifier que c'est la même chose, vous pouvez
rechercher les sept différences, il n'y en a
pas de disponible dans toutes les tailles s m
l  Taille XL XXL et pieuvre si vous avez
huit bras
je plaisante je ne suis pas aussi drôle que vous les
gars
et enfin cerisola gotto si vous
précommandez le DV
vous obtiendrez le scénario officiel du
film signé par surio Qatar c'est la
meilleure chose qui soit  Piyush tour par encore
magnum Redbridge y  tu dois les aider à
devenir [ __ ] de riches faire qu'il pleuve peu d'
avoir de l'argent alors par
oh tu m'as appelé du skipper ou de la
caméra Palafox non et si tu n'as
pas d'argent
dirige l'argent de ta mère ou de je
ne connais pas les gens  dans la rue
mystérieuse,
donnez-le-lui,
je veux dire, vous n'êtes pas obligé de le donner aux
pauvres, vous devez le donner pour poursuivre en justice la
bonne dame d'anniversaire, alors dites, cliquez ici
pour acheter de la merde, façon école vétérinaire, ok un
Pattinson le plus rapide, un autre cool Entre
Nous sur Asperger curseur hoopla aqua
Eddie Bisou Bisou Bisou Bisou Bisou
Bisou dis que tu es désolé
Bisou Bisou Bisou vidéo Danny Bisou
Bisou une webview
Bisou Bisou d'
accord allez hé elle m'a vite dit
non